[Music]
about 9 30. I was by myself on the beach
there was two people in the water
already
I heard screaming
and I saw the blood
seems like more and more sharks were
arriving in Cape Cod each year but not
until the poor boy was killed it really
seemed like okay now they're here it's
never quite been the same since the
Fatal attack it did cause a rift in the
community
this is a beautiful young man who lost
his life because we've been sitting
doing nothing
violence can intersect any moment but
one wouldn't have thought of the sunny
afternoon off the coast of New England
Shadow was waiting
it's easy to get caught up in the Jaws
angle to things it was like this look
around and take our eye off the bigger
picture
the research we're doing is really to
learn more about these animals so that
we can prevent a bad interaction with a
shark
sharks they're attracted by the seals
and they're a lot of seals because of
the rain manual protection act you can't
touch them you can't look at them you
can't even yell at them as you go past
them but there's something else going on
down there the water's warm so
everything's marching North
human activities have imbalanced the
ecosystem we have a problem here ladies
and gentlemen and the problem is
man-made we like to think that our lives
are orderly but we don't find
cooperation from the natural world did
you see that a few are these people are
acting like the oceans they're a little
plague mountains not doesn't work that
way we're right in the damn swimming
area Marine balanced equation means
humans are part of the equation finding
that balance is not easy
humankind must learn humility in the
face of nature
[Music]
foreign